In the cold, disciplined halls of 19th-century Prussian military academies, young men didn't fight to win.
They fought to earn a scar, a thin, deliberate cut across the cheek, menser.
They called it a ritual where courage wasn't measured in victories, but in the willingness to take a wound.
And that wound? It wasn't just flesh. It was currency.
A smite. A slight.
A badge sewn into the fabric of their reputation, proof they'd been marked by the elite, the wounded, the ones who turned pain into prestige.
Now, imagine that logic-twisted, refined, weaponized not in a barracks, but in the quiet ledgers of human connection.
That's the maven's game.
While most people scramble to smooth over the rough edges of social life, to bury the small offenses beneath polite smiles and forgotten apologies,
the maven does something else.
The maven does something else.
The maven financialized friction, every canceled plan, every birthday ignored, every half-hearted all think about it,
or, that's interesting, delivered with the enthusiasm of a man reading a tax code.
These aren't just slights. They're deposits.
And you? You're the banker.
Here's how it works.
First, you build the archive, not of grand betrayals, those are rare, like gold in a riverbed, but of the micro-slights.
The way they glanced at their phone mid-conversation, the tone in their voice when they said,
We'll see, instead of, Yes.
These are the cannonballs of social debt, small but heavy, sinking into the ledger with every passing day.
You don't confront them.
You don't even mention them.
You let them accrue interest.
Silence becomes your currency.
A cold shoulder here, a withheld text there, just enough to make them wonder, just enough to keep them guessing,
because the real power isn't in the debt itself.
It's in the uncertainty of it.
You're not a creditor demanding payment.
You're a ghost in the ledger haunting them with the knowledge that something is owed, but never quite what.
Then, you score them, not on kindness, not on loyalty, but on reserves.
Who's running on empty?
Who's still got a little credit left?
Who's already bankrupt in your eyes?
By reducing relationships to numbers, you remove the messiness of human connection.
No more spontaneous affection.
No more uncalculated trust.
Just a spreadsheet of who owes you what, and how much leverage you hold.
It's efficient.
It's ruthless.
And it's the opposite of love.
But the best part, when you need a boost, when the ego feels fragile, when the world's rewards start to waver,
you liquidate, you dig into the vault of old slights.
Remember last year when you said you'd help and then forgot?
And watch as the apology rushes in like a drug.
The relief on their face.
The scramble to make it right.
It's not forgiveness you're after.
It's confirmation.
Proof that you're still the one holding the scales.
Proof that you're the only one who sees the ledger.
And for a moment, in that rush of righteous indignation, you feel powerful, anti-fragili, unshakable.
But here's the catch.
You don't just become the banker.
You become the auditor.
Every handshake is a transaction.
Every hug a potential liability.
You're the only person in the room who still believes in the social credit of the slight that every interaction is a balance sheet.
Every relationship alone that's never quite repaid.
And the worst part?
They know it too.
Not in words, but in the way they flinch when you walk in the room.
In the way they start calculating their own ledger before they even speak.
Forgiveness, they say, is losing leverage.
Remembering is building a throne.
So you sit.
You wait.
And you let the debt accumulate.
Because in the end, the maven doesn't just want to be right.
They want to be the only one who remembers the numbers.